we are behind the scenes of the YouTube
gaming live show Franchesca doing makeup
we've got all kinds of what's up I've
got really quiet interrupts yeah you got
really loud what is that that simmer
down
what is this is a camera okay yes Troy
is memorable yeah I do cameras yeah I'm
sweating well that's probably just a
genetic thing we'll work on that Matt
how's it going bud yeah we just did an
unboxing video together did you guys see
it
we're gonna do one on the show as well
oh yeah yeah so stay tuned we're
unboxing the PlayStation VR and I'm
actually gonna have that cuff on my
channel so you guys will see it here in
a second or it will be a separate video
I'm not sure working hard
waiting hardly to it does bestseller
yeah
[Applause]
oh gosh Peter oh boy should we go here
we go here we go we're going in here
then
it's looking good
hey guys nadeshot i'm bringing you a
brand new video and that's the show guys
this is really really really fun fun
that video at the beginning of this
video is from a few days ago I just woke
up from a nap
it was like an accidental nap Jenna came
in my room and I was confused I thought
the zombie apocalypse was happening I
sent Maddie in to get you I was like
Goku though I thought he was a zombie do
your job Manny I'm having a little bit
of trouble with my camera I don't know
if I can even possibly show it to you
because I'm filming with it but when I
pulled it down it doesn't snap anymore
I'll have to show you with another
camera
what does they even do what's what do
your puppy thing oh oh this you will get
Pokemon with it you just push the button
that you catch it so we've got to go run
some errands I still haven't got a couch
to replace souther couch don't even show
them in there it's gross no it's bad
like look at the stuff everywhere I've
just been traveling and there's just
been no time so that's on the Julis
today tomorrow clean our parents are
coming into town a lot of stuff has
happened so let's go see if we can get
these tasks done do you think we can
maybe film a sunset drone shot yeah let
me just pull some more time at you but
well I have the drone it's in here yeah
look at this new little case I got for
it it fits in that and the controller is
in here hey I know wild
necessities I'm ready for the day we're
on our way to the furniture store I'm
feeling did you blog in this furniture
store before quickly I was in a very big
rush
we're going to go we're gonna try to get
the couch we're gonna see what we can
see I looked online they owned nicely
they said she's alone I didn't look at
the couch luxury was it as a market you
know the market oh my god do you think
it'd be very different up a drone out
just to get establishing shots all this
play went away
like I would just send it right up just
right up like that down
I think I'm going to do it wait a minute
what design HPV for everyone true
have you not been you or even about a
cup no we don't even board but I
remember I push my button push my button
push my button thank you
oh I love it it would look really good
for filming you would uh pardon me I was
kidding we hate this is real welcoming
into my home real welcoming I'd love it
I like them a lot Wow
[Music]
what is that I guess there's a reason
it's 30% off
maybe that's 80% off I'm gonna go with
$349 three nine I'm gonna go with
originally 1,500 oh what a deal
talk to me when it's free
[Music]
Oh
I'm stronger to get his ball
this one
[Music]
like we just walked in okay cool this
whole this push this button three push
it the way I put I didn't push it
I caught it you caught it what was it
come on
I say I hate it so much
let's shop oh it's not real
I like the attract we're having a little
bit of luck a little bit we are buying a
couch today please hold we come in from
the right let's do that action again
ready let's go over here she mess with
the shot I'm sitting over here
Oh
to the shot that's a good take I'll
accept it I'll mark that one
oh right there it's actually two feet
away
bloomers now
as a designer I would say bloomers is
now I'm reading bloomers first bloomers
is now like real really strong and then
they've got the logo and then
Scandinavian denies that like I think
you're not you're selling me
bloomers and see maybe you guys
how many times have you guys seen us in
the store at least seven at this point
maybe I can get this in sort of a
different configuration
I like this but I don't wanna get the
same couches in that that's a nice color
that's the bath yeah well that is back
of it back of the leather version it's
beautiful oh I found a light we could
get from that format four and a half
Justine speaks four and a half my feet
more to half my feet a lot to go back
shows about the same size
yeah okay I think this couch is the one
oh wait would you think we should get
like a little footrest like this table
calibrating the career always a gallery
[Music]
you
I hate it oh I'm gonna vomit oh it's
cool okay you're next use this system no
I don't like it I hate this game this
was such a stupid